[Music]
on this sunday night
the death toll from covet 19 grows in
canada
stopping the crisis from getting worse
if we don't
prevent this from occurring it will just
get out of control and be too late and
the cross-country debate over easing
health restrictions
the collateral crisis involving children
and why er
doctors are sounding the alarm plus
preserving
black american sign language if there's
nothing
then there's something we have to do
about it the history behind the dialect
for the hearing impaired
and the montreal musician who went from
tick-tock
to the tonight show
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with a reminder of
the toll of this pandemic
in canada we didn't imagine this when we
first learned about the novel
coronavirus
a year ago as of today more than 20 000
canadians
have lost their lives to covet 19. daily
new case numbers have gone down
over the past few weeks but canada's top
health officials say
the risk remains high the new highly
infectious strains pose a danger to
cases surging again
even so some provinces are beginning to
lift restrictions
mike delay has our top story tonight
albertans are getting a break tough
coveted 19 restrictions will begin
easing on february 8th
starting with restaurants and gyms so
when you can come
just leave the house and go somewhere
else where a human being can actually
keep you accountable
i think is big in quebec premier
francois lugo has set his sights on the
same date to give the economy much
needed oxygen
both provinces are working off the same
data national numbers
are trending downward the seven day
average from january 22nd to 28th
dropped under 5 000 cases roughly where
the country was
in mid-november but still nowhere near
the summer lows
and with the national positivity rate
over 4 percent canadian chief public
health officer dr theresa tan maintains
covet 19 control measures must be strong
and sustained
a considerable concern has been the slow
rollout of the vaccine
the potential impact of the new variant
first found in the uk
which is about 50 percent more
transmissible than other variants
and my fear is that by easing
restrictions now
we're putting ourselves in a place where
we're again going to be reactive rather
than proactive
if we don't prevent this from occurring
it will just get out of control and be
too late and that's not hyperbole the uk
saw its cases quadruple in only a month
after the variant became the predominant
strain leading to a third national
lockdown
it's because of the uk example that new
brunswick has taken a different approach
to easing restrictions
the size of household bubbles will
increase but so too will strict
quarantine rules for out-of-province
visitors
that strategy aligns with the canadian
shield a proposal by
leading public health experts which
argues for severe short-term
restrictions
similar to what was implemented in
australia and new zealand
this is in a sense a chance for us to
kind of redo what we failed to do last
spring
which is to really eliminate these
variants before they really spread
across the community
but for it to work canadians will have
to buy in and there's no
certainty in that mike turley global
news toronto
there's a new concern emerging from this
pandemic emergency room doctors in many
parts of canada say they're seeing more
cases of child abuse
they believe it's a result of the
lockdowns and restrictions and as morgan
campbell explains
there are fears if these cases go under
reported and help isn't found for these
families
there could be another health crisis
the novel coronavirus has forced many
canadians indoors during the winter
months and some doctors say
that may be one of the causes behind a
worrying trend
reports of child abuse have decreased
significantly
during the pandemic and we don't think
that's because
there are less concerns since september
dr michelle ward has seen and treated
more than twice as many infants
from maltreatment concerns children
under the age of one needing medical
attention
for fractures and head trauma
particularly
injuries to the brain to the eyes
that can happen when force is used with
a child
even in those moments can have lifelong
consequences
in vancouver dr nita jain co-authored a
study looking into
child abuse neglect and its connection
to the covit 19 pandemic
in the early months the bc children's
hospital where she works
believed many abuse and neglect cases
were going underreported
but during the second wave a new problem
a rise in the number of nutritional
neglect and starvation these are i
believe families that were just
so stretched and so stressed
that we we didn't recognize
as a society how much they were
struggling the isaac walton killum
hospital in halifax treats youth across
the maritimes who need
specialized care which gives doctors a
snapshot of what may be happening
in that region which means children are
better monitored
those systems are are in place
and so you're right that very well may
be one of the factors that's explaining
the differences that we're seeing
between regions
doctors and advocates are also
highlighting the pandemic
as an especially tough time for new
parents
who are isolated from family and friends
beyond the family
beyond the community we need our policy
makers to make investments in the care
of our children
those who work in child welfare and
advocacy say
they want parents to come forward if
they are struggling and to erase the
stigma
of asking for help morgan campbell
global news toronto
after months of diplomatic disputes and
delays the team from the world health
organization got its first look at the
animal market in china where kova 19 was
first detected
there was a heavy security presence at
the now shuttered market
and the site has been heavily sanitized
the team plans to visit more markets as
well as hospitals and labs
but the probe has become highly
politicized china has been accused of a
cover-up
and to avoid blame for how it handled
the crisis the country has rejected
calls for an
independent investigation in the u.s
it'll be a tough week for president joe
biden
he's facing a huge battle to get a 1.9
trillion dollar covet 19 relief bill
passed by congress it's critical for the
millions of
unemployed americans and the millions
waiting to be vaccinated
here's jennifer johnson a storm is
brewing at the white house after 10
republican senators asked for a meeting
with president joe biden
to consider their counter proposal 600
billion dollar coven 19 relief plan
the president's package more than three
times that amount
has little to no gop support if you want
unity if you want bipartisanship you
ought to start with a group that's shown
it's willing to work together
for common solution bringing america
together
uniting our people republicans using the
president's own inauguration words
against him
the president's team says it will work
with the gop but it needs to be fast
after more than 1.7 million americans
filed for unemployment the past two
weeks
this is an unprecedented crisis but
really the cost of inaction the cost of
failing to do this or delaying for
another month really outweighs the cost
of taking this action
president biden wants congress to pass
the bill this week before the senate is
bogged down with former president donald
trump's impeachment trial
i don't care what anybody says we have
got to deal with this pandemic we have
got to make sure that we are producing
the vaccines that we need
and get those vaccines into the arms of
people 90 billion dollars in the bill
will pay for a federal vaccination
program
as new more transmissible variants are
quickly spreading across the country
the surge that is likely to occur with
this new variant from england
is going to happen in the next 6 to 14
weeks we are going to see something like
we have not seen yet
in this country with the vaccine supply
still low federal health officials
are particularly concerned about these
new variants surging in people over 65
they say while hospitalizations have
leveled off there is a hurricane coming
jennifer johnson global news washington
the war vet who raised millions for the
british health care system at the
beginning of the pandemic is now in
hospital with coveted 19.
captain tom moore's daughter shared the
news on twitter she says he's not an icu
but needs help breathing
moore has been battling pneumonia and
tested positive for the virus last week
sir tom who was knighted by the queen in
july
is three months away from turning a
hundred and one
we have breaking news tonight myanmar's
aung san tsuchi has been detained
she and other senior figures from
myanmar's ruling party were reportedly
arrested in an early morning raid
the military said a coup could not be
ruled out if complaints of widespread
voting fraud in last november's election
were ignored the canadian government is
condemning the detention of thousands of
protesters in russia
and calling for their release for weeks
supporters of the country's opposition
leader
alexei navalny have been protesting his
arrest
ross lord has the latest on the unrest
rattling russia
despite two weekends of nationwide
protests russian president vladimir
putin has not freed his most prominent
opponent
alexei navalny but those who study
russia have noticed
something significant there are
disturbing signs for the food regime
because the
people of russia seem to be losing their
fear
there is a growing force of civil
society
there is increasing concern about
the dire economic conditions in russia
police detained thousands of protesters
in moscow
as large crowds demanding navalny's
release marched towards the prison where
he's being held
navalny was poisoned last summer falling
into a coma
after recovering in germany he flew home
to moscow two weeks ago
and was immediately arrested at this
weekend's protests
riot police clubbed protesters with
batons
released tear gas and shot stun guns
i can't breathe i'm telling the truth
let me go said this protester
subdued on a sidewalk the new american
administration is taking a dim
view of the police response secretary of
state anthony blinken says
the u.s condemns the persistent use of
harsh tactics
against peaceful protesters and
journalists lincoln also renewed a call
for russia to
release those detained for exercising
their human rights
including alexey navalny in moscow
police imposed a security lockdown
closing off streets and public transit
stations but some
suggest the crackdown won't work forever
the crucial tipping point
is a loss of nerve that's what we saw in
eastern europe that's when regimes
collapsed
we are not there yet but i think
the kremlin is very worried he says
growing international support could keep
navalny safe
and make protesters even more determined
they plan to protest at his court
appearance tuesday
where he faces a possible prison
sentence stemming from a 2014
embezzlement conviction
a case europe's top human rights court
called politically motivated
ross lord global news in
india farmers protesting new agriculture
laws have turned to a hunger strike
they're trying to show the movement is
peaceful after recent demonstrations
turned violent
since november tens of thousands of
farmers have capped out near the indian
capital
demanding the government repeal laws
they say will devastate their earnings
and favor larger corporations
coming up the contentious role of social
media is it a referral service
it was a fiery night in sicily lava spew
down the slopes of mount aetna in
another spectacular eruption
the volcanic activity was expected and
the surrounding area was secured
no injuries were reported aetna is
europe's most active volcano it has
already erupted several times
since the new year the days of web
giants like facebook resisting content
regulation
seem to be over there's now a move to
give them guard rails to win back
trust but it's unclear exactly how
canada will do that in a way which will
be acceptable to the social media site
here's michael couture we welcome
regulation
we're calling for more of it a decidedly
different tone from facebook before a
parliamentary committee hearing
in the past web giants like facebook
have resisted regulations by governments
but the canadian head of the social
media platform
is signaling a shift regulations can set
baseline standards for what kind of
content is prohibited online and
requires social media companies to build
systems
to enforce these standards the status
quo of having private companies decide
what is and isn't acceptable speech
online
is not sustainable longer term and lacks
transparency the change comes from the
top
last year facebook ceo mark zuckerberg
said if there aren't standards
then people could lose faith in
institutions of technology
some observers believe it's part of a
strategy
to appear more open they accept a
certain type of regulation that doesn't
undermine their business model and in
fact might even help them
um both in relation to other competitors
but also helps them make these tough
decisions around what kind of speech
should stay on or stay off
canada is looking at content regulation
separately from content remuneration
which is an even bigger issue
facebook is pushing back against
australia's model
to have web giants pay news
organizations for content shared on
their platforms
chan says facebook offers a referral
value
newspaper publishers in canada benefit
from free distribution
on facebook which we estimate to be on
the order of
hundreds of millions of dollars some mps
push back on that sense of benevolence
newspapers are dropping like flies in
this country
and this is one of the biggest issue if
not the biggest
issue right now in that industry is
there they're getting nothing from you
heritage minister stefan gilbeau told
the committee the government is looking
at a made in canada formula
to compensate news organizations for
their content shared on digital
platforms
the minister says legislation for both
remuneration
and regulation is coming soon michael
couter global news ottawa
still ahead the history behind black
american sign language
monday marks the beginning of black
history month it's an opportunity to
celebrate the identity
and culture of the black community that
includes looking at communication
through a different lens black american
sign language has been the subject of
research projects books
and now viral videos as natty stewart
reports the increased visibility
is prompting calls for a deeper
understanding of the black deaf
community
in canada
nakia smith's viral social media videos
are what caught the eyes of producers at
netflix
[Music]
as she communicated using black american
sign language
or black asl a language many people
know little about but for the black deaf
community in the united states
it's how they communicate people have
said when they watch black deaf people
use sign language
they definitely notice a difference it
is a language dr carolyn mccaskill has
gone to great lengths to preserve
celebrate and share she grew up in the
segregated south at first
going to the alabama school for the
negro deaf and blind
but when i remained there and i moved to
the white
school again in 1968
i didn't understand the teachers the
same way
even though both schools were 15 minutes
apart they were pretty close
it was really quite a difference in
three different states in
black death institutes um for example
the bathroom sign in north carolina
black death institute was that sign for
bathroom
in virginia that was the sign for
bathroom that's when mccaskill realized
there was a difference
in the way black deaf people signed
versus their white counterparts
in part because of the influence of
ebonics or african-american slang
and partly because this is what happens
in segregated communities
we know from decades of sociolinguistic
research that in communities like this
that are
separated their language variety is
going to emerge
mccaskill worked with ceo lucas from
gallaudet university
and rochester institute of technology
associate professor dr
joseph hill among others to produce a
book and a series of videos about the
history
and unique cultural differences of black
asl
[Applause]
but since last summer amidst widespread
black lives matter protests
interest in black asl has significantly
increased
similarly there are calls in canada for
more recognition of the black deaf
community here
something both mccaskill and hill
support is there a book about us
is there a film about us is there
research about us who am i
if there's nothing then there's
something we have to do about it
something has to be done
[Music]
they're also encouraged by a new
generation introducing more
people to the hidden treasure that is
black asl
nadia stark global news vancouver
global news will launch a new online
series called perspectives with in-depth
stories looking at the lives of
racialized communities
in canada it begins tomorrow so check it
out
on globalnews.ca
[Music]
up next the social media star turning
online tirades
into tunes
a four-year-old discovered this
well-preserved dinosaur footprint on a
beach in wales
it measures 10 centimeters long
scientists don't know which dinosaur
made the imprint but believe it dates
back
220 million years the fossil which has
been taken to the national museum could
help them learn more about
how dinosaurs walked there's no arguing
that online debates can get heated these
days
scrolling through social media it's easy
to find fights among strangers
family members and celebrities well one
montreal man has turned that online
trash talk
into treasure on tick-tock dan spector
has the story
yeah it's crazy i i have no idea it's
like a dream
he calls himself lubilen and from
somewhere in montreal's southwest
the musician has been gaining worldwide
fame by turning internet drama
into songs this one has been seen nearly
33 million times on tick tock
and i just thought how funny would it be
to uh take something really stupid like
an argument on the internet and then
spend days like trying to craft a
beautiful song around it
another 33 million views for this
exchange about an apartment listing
[Music]
[Music]
a few months ago he was just another
struggling musician trying to find his
way
some of his early videos like this
little nas x choir cover
gained some traction
[Music]
but the first internet drama video
changed everything
first two hours it had 270 000 views and
another hour had reached a million and
then in another hour it had done two
million
the second one cemented his place as a
viral sensation
and brought him to places he never
imagined i was just like oh this is kind
of like a jimmy fallon sense of humor
thing
uh so when i got the email i was i just
like lost my mind
[Music]
suddenly jimmy fallon and actress alison
brie were in the next video
on a debate about salad dressings what's
up how you doing
lubalin does not know exactly where the
journey will take him next
he's just released a single of what he
calls his not so funny music
and says high profile artists are lining
up to collaborate
it's people that i would never have
imagined would reach out to me
dan spector global news montreal
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada
is annapolis valley in nova scotia thank
you so much for watching donna friesen
is back at the desk tomorrow and i'll
see you
on thursday have a great night and a
great week